Dianne Feinstein Senator Dianne
Feinstein she is upset that the CIA
might be spying on the Senate ironic
because she might have been the one to
get us in this mess in the first place
she took it to the Senate floor let's
take a look questions related to who had
authorized and conducted the search and
what legal basis the CIA claimed gave it
authority to conduct the search again
the CIA has not provided answers to any
of my questions my letter also laid out
my concern about the legal and
constitutional implications of the CIA's
actions based on what director Brennan
has informed us I have grave concerns
that the CIA search may well have
violated the separation of powers
principles embodied in the United States
Constitution including the Speech and
Debate clause it may have undermined the
constitutional framework essential to
effective congressional oversight of
intelligence activities or any other
government function okay so that's
pretty serious stuff if the Senate is
spying on the CIA of course she didn't
have a problem when the Senate was
spying on us she voted for most of that
stuff if not all of it CIA director John
Brennan responded to miss Feinstein the
the matter is being dealt with in the
appropriate way being looked at by the
right authorities and the facts will
come out but let me assure you that CIA
in no way was spying on the SSCI or the
senate we greatly respect the separation
of powers between the executive branch
and legislative branch now I don't see
why we'd have any reason to think that
someone in power at the CIA or the NSA
might be lying unless it's happened
before what I wanted to see is if you
could give me a yes or no answer to the
question does the NSA collect any type
of data at all on millions or hundreds
of millions of Americans no sir it does
not not wittingly
there are cases where they could
inadvertently perhaps collect but not
not wittingly and by not wittingly of
course we now know he means yes we did
and we do okay so first question pretty
simple out of the gate can we trust any
of these people forget Feinstein for a
second can we trust any of them when
they say what they're doing or what
they're not doing we clearly have a
precedent showing that no we can't but
one thing I'm kind of in the midst of
all this awful lying and going back and
forth between branches of government
this is a fight between two different
branches of government we would have
never seen in the pre Snowden day so I'm
glad that at least she publicly said hey
this is they're spying on us they're not
supposed to be doing that yeah so let's
get to the separation of powers in a
second do you think we can trust any of
these people we have clapper knowingly
lied nothing's happened to him he's
still in all the big meetings he has not
been certainly not I mean I think a
reasonable expectation of privacy is
unreasonable now I think it's a kind of
come out now now that we have technology
I think we're more maybe we're more or
more it's more visible that we can see
that this is actually happening where
we're using these leaks whereas in the
past you know hey maybe they were spying
on us too yo I just think that maybe now
we're more aware of it yeah so the
separation of powers you brought up i
think is the interesting part is because
nobody talks about how the government
supposed to work anymore but we have
three branches of government that you
learn in politics 101 and they're
supposed to keep each other in check
that's the whole point but when she says
that they do regular people hear that
and realize what a sort of you serpin of
power is really going on well I think
previously they would have worked in
tandem were or kept this quiet and we're
all supposed to just trust our
government and know that they have
what's best for us in mind and you know
when they say spy on us and breach our
security and civil rights it's okay cuz
it's fully the greater good but maybe
not now huh yeah you think you think
maybe not what do you make of the
separation of powers part is alright we
just dumb down our society part to the
point where would people say things like
that that I don't think it really breaks
through the ether sort of and why it's
important to talk about you got to think
about our culture and
terms of what we do every single day
right we're on Facebook we're on twitter
we're stalking each other we're spying
on each other's private lives and stuff
like that I think the idea that the
government is doing it also it should a
not be a surprise what do they have like
probably Facebook plus or something pick
the pace the paid version right where
they can let go and you know dig on you
and figure out what's going on but I
think that a people just are not that
phase by it they expect to be stocked
they expect to be followed and you know
when you have a president right who says
I don't need Congress to do anything I
can just take a pen and you know right
write a bill and I got a bypass oh
that's right you can just do what every
once and you know i'm not you know it
doesn't surprise me it shouldn't
surprise any of us yeah so is the really
scary part here that if the CIA is
spying on Congress so spying on another
branch of government what what makes us
think they're not spying on Obama too
because I mean people are starting to
talk about that we have no reason to
think if they went ahead and figured out
some legal justification to spy on
Congress why and the Senate why not the
executive branch do what makes you think
obama isn't isn't in on it first wady
too well that equally scary oh
absolutely well I mean you know since
Obama resigned Frank Underwood is now
president I think that it's pretty clear
that you know we like we shouldn't you
know not expect these kind of things to
happen for sure but uh you know it's a
whole culture of of Washington of like
we're going to be real nice and we're
going to tell you all these like pretty
things to your face but then we are
going to go you know in the back room
and then check out your biometrics and
figure out exactly where you are and
what you're doing and how you're going
to vote so we can then better market to
you to figure out you know how we can
stay in back yeah I'm glad you mentioned
house of cards actually because it seems
to me that with all this NSA stuff going
on there's so little trust in government
and then at the same time house of cards
come out and of course it's a fictitious
show but everyone keeps saying oh it's
ninety percent real that's what all the
pundits say that's what all the actors
say so it's sort of like we just have no
clue what's going on should we just give
up having any real insight into how this
operates and how many people they have
to kill and drugs they have to do and
marriages they have to ruin got it to
make it happen we gotta try we can do
the best we can you we do the best we
can with what we have with the
information we have the information we
have was probably not so good
probably it infirm list but I do like I
did appreciate the transparencies on at
least one side here yeah is this
incredibly disingenuous of Feinstein who
had no problem voting obviously for the
Patriot but plenty of other I mean she
knew about the domestic spying and
suddenly it's about her and her
computers and her investigation and help
I have some righteous indignation right
well a what does she have to hide for
you have fat hi miss Feinstein like
what's going on over there you you know
not actually doing any congressional
work or you just like on etsy all day
you know I don't know and gently selling
brother for sure it seems like she would
she would be a kind of person who does
that but uh you know like like no I've
now I've never been a big fan you know
quite honestly i think that i think that
uh you know when you look at her her
voting record as far as you know heard
her hypocritical kind of stance now is
really pretty obvious yeah and then
that's what a lot of people are talking
about so final thought on this is this
the type of thing because it's about the
Senate and if they know one thing it's
self-preservation is this the type of
thing that maybe we'll push back against
the NSA a little bit more because they
don't really care what's happening to us
but when it's happening to them maybe
this thing will get it to critical mass
and then you'll have people like Rand
Paul who's been hugely against it so
it's sort of going on both sides of the
aisle so maybe some goodness here I do
like well before sometimes people had
said oh well you're crazy if you think
they're spying on you don't be paranoid
don't be delusional it's not paranoid
delusion especially if we have a known
hypocrite in public office telling us
this is happening yeah I hypocrite in
public office can you blow it certainly
yeah I've ever never heard of that
shocking I I think that you know from a
public standpoint it's up to us to
actually care about you know and if we
start banging the drum we say like hey
we're not going to stand for this this
is ridiculous then then we'll get sort
of you know maybe some some good stuff
happening there